hey guys today I'm going to try to
provide you an answer on a question that
has been bothering a huge amount of us
Game of Thrones fans ever since the
season 2 finale and it to be exact I'll
try to give you an answer on a question
how did Samuel Tarly survive being
surrounded by a vast horde of white sand
notice by their leader a white Walker as
we all know Sam gran and the Lord said
were gathering dung for fuel around the
fist of the first man when all of a
sudden they heard the horn being blown
they heard three horn blasts the warning
call for White Walkers the tree started
running immediately back to the fist but
Sam's companions were faster and Sam's
left behind as a blizzard enveloped the
entire plateau and the Sam so shadowy
figures moving through the blowing snow
Sam sought refuge behind a rock a few
months later while Samuel got terrified
by horde whites the White Walkers
seemingly known as Sam but appeared to
ignore him for unknown reasons riding
past him atop of on that horse leading
the Horde for an invasion on the fist of
the first man location of the camp of
the Nights Watch the first possible
explanation might be in effect that
White Walkers have a tendency to let one
man survive so that man could tell the
tales about them
so perhaps the white Walker decided to
spare Simone's life so Sam could spread
the word about the battle that happened
shortly after this encounter about the
first open confrontation between men and
the White Walkers since the long night
about a battle the fist of the first man
which only a handful of the Brothers of
the Nights Watch managed to survive
along with Lord Commander Mormont
well this explanation does make sense
and most certainly is within the realm
of possibilities by rewatching and
reconsidering the same scene the real
truth might be in a theory that the
white Walker did not even know this Sam
even though it really seems like he did
which is actually supported with a few
proofs as much as it looks like Sam was
terrified upon finding out that white
Walker known as him and as much as it
looks like those two had an eye contact
there's a possibility that the
showrunners purposely shot that scene
the way they did in order to wrap up the
season with cliffhanger the shot of the
undead horse in the close-up shot of the
white walkers face was clearly intended
to be from Sam's perspective as it was
accompanying with his reaction but when
we get to see Dwyer shot we can actually
see that the only rock behind which Sam
could hide was in front of the white
Walker and his
armie not beside him meaning that Sam
was not visible from the White Walkers
perspective nor was the white Walker
visible from Sam's at least not in that
scene therefore say mas police arrived
because the white Walker did not
actually seem and as always let me know
your opinion about all of this in the
comment section down below do you think
Sam survived because the white Walker
decided that he would be a good
storyteller or do you think the white
Walker did not even notice him I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]